FOR US.
LET'S DISCUSS THIS WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION SECRETARY PETE
BUTTIGIEG.
MR. SECRETARY, THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
I UNDERSTAND YOU JUST SPOKE
DIRECTLY WITH THE CEO OF
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES.
DID YOU GET ANY EXPLANATION AT
ALL FOR THIS HORRENDOUS MELTDOWN
OF EPIC PROPORTIONS?
>> MELTDOWN IS THE RIGHT WORD.
THIS IS AN UNACCEPTABLE
SITUATION.
YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
PASSENGERS WHO ARE STRANDED.
YOU LOOK AT HOW HARD IT IS TO
GET SOMEBODY ON THE PHONE TO
ADDRESS IT.
FROM WHAT I CAN TELL SOUTHWEST
IS UNABLE TO LOCATE EVEN WHERE
THEIR OWN CREWS ARE LET ALONE
THEIR OWN PASSENGERS AND
BAGGAGE.
SO I CONVEYED TO THE CEO OUR
EXPECTATION THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO GO ABOVE AND BEYOND TO TAKE
CARE OF PASSENGERS AND ADDRESS
THIS.
THEY INDICATED A NUMBER OF
ISSUES WITH SYSTEMS, LEGACY
SYSTEMS FOR MANAGING THEIR
SCHEDULE AND WHERE THEIR CREWS
ARE BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE
REST OF THE AVIATION SYSTEM HAS
BEEN ON THE ROAD TO RECOVERY
SINCE THE WORST DAYS OF THE
STORM GOING INTO FRIDAY OF LAST
WEEK.
AS OF TODAY, AS I'M LOOKING AT
THE DIFFERENT AIRLINES, MOST OF
THEM ARE IN THE LOW SINGLE
DIGITS IN TERMS OF CANCELLATION
RATES AVERAGING ABOUT 5% FOR ALL
OF THE OTHER AIRLINES.
FOR SOUTHWEST RIGHT NOW, WE
APPEAR TO BE NORTH OF 70%.
SO THEIR SYSTEM REALLY HAS
COMPLETELY MELTED DOWN AND I
MADE CLEAR THAT OUR DEPARTMENT
WILL BE HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES TO
GET THEM THROUGH THIS SITUATION
AND MAKE SURE THIS CAN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN.
>> LEARN THE LESS S LESSONS OF
DISASTER.
IT'S SOUTHWEST AIRLINES.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
THAT SITUATION YOU HAD WITH THE
CEO OF SOUTHWEST AIRLINES AND
WHAT IS HE DOING?
WHAT ARE THEY DOING TO CORRECT
THESE MAJOR ISSUES?
>> WELL, OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST YEAR, AS YOU KNOW, WE'VE
SEEN A NUMBER OF ISSUES WITH THE
DIFFERENT AIRLINES AND IN THE
SUMMER IN PARTICULAR, WE PRESSED
THEM TO IMPROVE THEIR STANDARD
OF CUSTOMER SERVICE.
THEY PROVIDED COMMITMENTS IN
WRITING INCLUDING SOUTHWEST THEY
WOULD GO ABOVE THE PREVIOUS
LEVEL OF WHAT YOU DO TO TAKE
CARE OF CUSTOMERS WITH THINGS
LIKE COVERING THE COST, IF YOU
GET STUCK AND YOU NEED A HOTEL
OR A MEAL IN ADDITION TO
REBOOKING YOU TO GET YOUR ON
YOUR WAY.
NOW THAT WE HAVE THOSE
COMMITMENTS THAT WERE MADE TO US
OVER THE SUMMER, WE'RE GOING TO
BE USING THAT AS A TOOL TO HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE AND I MADE THAT
CLEAR TO SOUTHWEST LEADERSHIP.
NOW, THEY DID -- THE CEO PLEDGED
TO ME THEY WILL NOT ONLY MEET
BUT EXCEED THE CUSTOMER SERVICE
STANDARDS AND COMMITMENTS THEY
MADE TO US IN THE PAST AND THAT
WE'RE IN A POSITION TO ENFORCE.
I ALSO TALKED WITH UNION
LEADERSHIP FROM THE PILOTS AND
FROM THE FLIGHT ATTENDANTS.
THEY'VE MADE CLEAR THEY HAVE
BEEN RAISING THE ALARM ABOUT
THESE ISSUES IN THEIR SYSTEMS
FOR SOMETIME AND THAT THIS
REALLY HAS TO DO WITH DECISIONS
AND CHOICES IN TERMS OF THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THIS AIRLINE
HAS MADE OR HAS FAILED TO MAKE
OVER THE YEARS THAT SEEM TO BE
CATCHING UP TO THEM NOW.
LOOK, WE ALL UNDERSTAND WHEN YOU
HAVE A MAJOR HISTORIC STORM
HITTING THE SYSTEM AND HITTING
HUBS IN EVERY PART OF THE
COUNTRY, WE KNOW THAT'S GOING TO
HAVE AN EFFECT ON THE AVIATION
SYSTEM BUT WHAT IS REALLY
CONCERNING HERE IS THAT WHILE
ALL OF THE OTHER PARTS OF THE
AVIATION SYSTEM HAVE BEEN MOVING
TOWARD RECOVERY AND GETTING
BETTER EACH DAY, IT'S ACTUALLY
BEEN MOVING THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION WITH THIS AIRLINE.
>> SO WHEN YOU SAY YOU'RE GOING
TO HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE, THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, THE
TRANSPORTATION DEPARTMENT,
YOU'RE THE SECRETARY OF
TRANSPORTATION, WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN?
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE?
>> WE HAVE ENFORCEMENT TOOLS WE
HAVE BEEN USING ESPECIALLY THIS
YEAR.
WE SAW FOR EXAMPLE A NUMBER OF
AIRLINES THAT HAD CANCELLATIONS.
THEY WEREN'T TAKING GOOD CARE OF
THEIR PASSENGERS THROUGH
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GET HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PASSENGERS THEIR
MONEY BACK TO THE TUNE OF
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
WE'RE ALSO IN A POSITION TO USE
ENFORCEMENT POWERS AND FINES TO
HOLD AIRLINES TO THE THINGS THAT
THEY HAVE NOW COMMITTED TO US,
PLEDGED TO US IN WRITING THEY'LL
DO.
THE INCREASED CUSTOMER SERVICE
COMMITMENTS WE EXTRACTED AROUND
THEM LIKE VOUCHERS AND YOU OUGHT
TO KNOW IF YOU'RE A PASSENGER IN
THE SITUATION NOW, YOU'RE
ENTITLED TO A CASH REFUND IF
YOUR FLIGHT IS CANCELLED AND
YOU'RE NOT TRAVELING AND ANOTHER
THING IF YOU'RE IN THIS
SITUATION AND THE AIRLINE IS
RESPONSIBLE, WHICH IS THE CASE,
YOU CAN GET THOSE VOUCHERS FOR
HOTELS, RESTAURANTS BUT WHAT I
TALKED ABOUT WITH THE SOUTHWEST
CEO IS THAT A PASSENGER
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO REQUEST THAT.
THEY NEED TO BE PROACTIVELY
OFFERING THAT.
HE PLEDGED THAT THEY WOULD.
AND AGAIN, WE'LL BE WATCHING TO
MAKE SURE THEY FOLLOW THROUGH.
>> WHAT IS YOUR ADVICE, MR.
SECRETARY, TO SOUTHWEST
CUSTOMERS WHO HAVE BEEN LEFT
STRANDED, THEY'RE DESPERATE NOW
AND STRUGGLING TO EVEN REACH
CUSTOMER SERVICE AT SOUTHWEST
AIRLINES.
WHAT IS YOUR ADVICE TO THEM?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THEY'RE IN AN UNACCEPTABLE
SITUATION.
THE DIFFICULTY OF GETTING ANYONE
ON THE PHONE AND BEING IN THIS
LEVEL OF CANCELLATION DISRUPTION
IN THE FIRST PLACE OUT OF A
MAJOR WEATHER EVENT ISN'T
ACCEPTABLE.
THERE IS INFORMATION THAT THE
AIRLINE PROVIDED.
THEY'VE SET UP, AS I UNDERSTAND
IT, A WEBSITE THAT YOU CAN USE
TO WITHOUT HAVING TO WAIT ON THE
PHONE TO GET YOUR MONEY BACK AND
TO PUT IN SOME OF THE EXPENSES
THAT YOU'RE EXPERIENCING, BUT I
WANT PASSENGERS TO KNOW WE HAVE
A WEBSITE, TOO.
AND WHEN AN AIRLINE IS FAILING
TO MEET CUSTOMER SERVICE
COMMITMENTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT WE HAVE IN BLACK AND WHITE
FOR AIRLINES TO LIVE UP TO, YOU
CAN LET US KNOW AND WE WILL
FOLLOW UP.
WE HAVE A CONSUMER PROTECTION
TEAM, THEY FOLLOW THROUGH
INDIVIDUALLY ON THESE KINDS OF
COMPLAINTS AND ISSUES SO IF
YOU'RE NOT GETTING RESULTS WITH
THE AIRLINE, LET US KNOW AND
WE'LL FOLLOW UP.
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT THE FLYING
PUBLIC AND WE HAVE YOUR BACK.
>> IS FLYING SOUTHWEST AIRLINES
MR. SECRETARY ON THE TABLE?
GETTING MORE MONEY FROM THEM,
POTENTIALLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT COULD REIMBURSE THESE
PASSENGERS, AS WELL?
>> POTENTIALLY, BUT IT SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO COME TO THAT.
I EXPECT THE AIRLINE TO GO AHEAD
AND DIRECTLY TAKE CARE OF
PASSENGERS WITH REIMBURSEMENTS
AND WHATEVER ELSE THEY NEED TO
DO TO COMPENSATE AND MAKE THEM
WHOLE.
IF THEY FAIL TO DO THAT, WE'LL
USE OUR AUTHORITIES TO MAKE IT
HAPPEN ON OUR SIDE.
>> HOW SEVERE WILL THE FINES BE?
>> WELL, IT'S LIKE AN KIND OF
ENFORCEMENT.
IT'S BASED ON THE LEVEL OF THE
FAILURE ON THE PART OF THE
AIRLINE.
BUT AGAIN, THE BOTTOM LINE IS
THIS SHOULDN'T BE HAPPENING IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
WE'LL FOLLOW THROUGH AND USE THE
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE FINES IF
THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES TO GET
SOMETHING DONE BUT THE REAL
QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU GET TO
THIS SITUATION WHERE AN AIRLINE
CAN'T EVEN SAY WHERE IT'S OWN
PERSONNEL ARE LET ALONE KEEP
TRACK OF PASSENGERS AND BAG
S.
THAT'S A SITUATION IS THAT
DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE SYSTEM WIDE
BECAUSE SOME CANCELLATIONS WITH
OTHER AIRLINES ARE BACK TO
NORMAL FAIR WEATHER RATES.
IT CONCENTRATED IN THE SYSTEMS
IN THE ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS ONE AIRLINE AND WHILE IT'S
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY AS A
COMPANY TO TAKE CARE OF THAT,
OBVIOUSLY, SOMETHING WE AS A
DEPARTMENT WILL TAKE A CLOSE
LOOK AT, TOO.
>> CLEARLY, THIS ARE SHORT FALLS
RIGHT NOW WITH THIS AIRLINE
PASSENGERS NEW BILL OF RIGHTS AS
IT WAS CALLED.
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN, MR.
SECRETARY, NOW, TO ENSURE PEOPLE
ARE COMPENSATED FOR THEIR
TROUBLES AND TO ENSURE THEY CAN
REACH A CUSTOMER SERVICE
REPRESENTATIVE IN SITUATIONS
LIKE THESE?
>> WE HAVE NEW TOOLS THAT DIDN'T
EXIST A FEW MONTHS AGO WITH THE
STEPPED UP COMMENTS WE WERE ABLE
TO EXTRACT OVER THE AIRLINES AS
WE PUSHED THEM OVER THE COURSE
OF THE SUMMER.
WE'LL USE THE TOOLS TO MAKE
SURE PASSENGERS GET RESULTS.
YOU HAVE SYSTEM ISSUES AND SOME
TO AN INDIVIDUAL COMPANY.
THIS COMPANY NEEDS TO STEP UP
AND WIN BACK THE TRUST OF
PASSENGERS AND EMPLOYEES.
EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN PUT IN A
HERB THE SITUATION.
I TALKED TO REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE PILOTS' UNION AND FLIGHT
ATTENDANTS' UNION.
THEY'RE FRUSTRATED AND OFTEN
STRANDED AND THEY THEMSELVES ARE
OFTEN SLEEPING IN AIRPORTS SO
YOU HAVE A COMPANY THAT'S GOT A
LOT OF CLEANING UP TO DO.
WE'LL WATCH AND USE THE TOOLS IN
OUR TOOL KIT TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
ARE MADE WHOLE.
>> DO YOU HAVE CONFIDENCE, MR.
SECRETARY, THAT SOUTHWEST
AIRLINES CAN ACTUALLY FIX ALL OF
THESE PROBLEMS?
BECAUSE A LOT OF US LOST
CONFIDENCE IN SOUTHWEST
AIRLINES.
>> I'LL TELL YOU, THAT'S THE
PLEDGE THEY MADE TO ME.
I'LL WATCH TO SEE IF THEY FOLLOW
THROUGH ON THAT PLEDGE AND
HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE IF THEY
DON'T.
>> ONCE AGAIN, HOLDING THEM
ACCOUNTABLE MEANS?
>> IT CAN MEAN ANYTHING FROM
FINES TO OTHER ENFORCEMENT
ORDERS, REGULATORY ACTIONS BUT
AGAIN, I'M HOPING THAT AIRLINES
DO THE RIGHT THING IN SITUATIONS
LIKE THIS BEFORE WE HAVE TO GET
INVOLVED.
IF YOU NEED TO, TURN TO US
THROUGH OUR CUSTOMER SERVICE
PROTECTION WEBSITE BUT, YOU
KNOW, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THEY REALLY NEED TO TAKE CARE OF
ON THE FRONT END.
WE'LL GET INVOLVED IF WE HAVE TO
AND OBVIOUSLY, REGARDLESS, WE'LL
GET INVOLVED IN TERMS OF
EXAMINING HOW THIS COULD HAVE
HAPPENED TO SUCH A BIG PART OF